this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
what's up guys michael here i don't know
if you've caught the vibe but things are
starting to feel
a bit like the end times are coming for
us all and there's nothing we can do
about it and all those books on your
shelf you're not gonna finish those all
the things you have queued up to watch
you're not gonna watch them all the
foods you never thought you'd get to eat
you're not gonna eat those in love kiss
it goodbye indeed in recent years the
possibility of us all getting don't look
up has become an almost constant
fixation in the media
and it's not hard to see why between
climate change once in a century
pandemic catastrophic weather events and
the always looming threat of nuclear war
we live with a perpetual sense of our
impending doom and we know we're not
alone in the sentiment the fact that
everything is hopeless and the world is
going to end soon practically feels like
common sense but are the gloom and
doomers right and if humans are totally
screwed what does our attitude about the
apocalypse say about us do doomers
secretly want the world to end let's
find out in this wisecrack edition why
we're all rooting for the apocalypse but
before we get into it i want to tell you
about this week's sponsor keeps now two
out of three men will experience some
form of male pattern baldness by the
time they're 35 but luckily keeps makes
it easier and more affordable for guys
to prevent hair loss the process starts
with a free consultation with a licensed
keeps doctor who can help decide which
treatment plan is right for you your
hair loss prevention medications
conveniently arrive at your door every
three months so you don't have to bother
with a calendar reminder or tying a
string around your finger plus because
keeps offers the generic versions of fda
approved medications for hair loss it's
more affordable than other treatment
options out there as your treatment plan
goes on you can message your keeps
doctor 24 7 to update them on how it's
going and to ask any questions you may
have and it's important to note that
while individual results may vary it
typically takes between four and six
months to start seeing results so get
started today to hang on to the hair you
have if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
wisecrack or click the link in the
description to receive 50 percent off
your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash wisecrack
now back to the show almost as long as
humanity has existed we've been trying
to figure out how it's all going to end
the vikings for instance told stories
about ragnarok the twilight of the gods
which was a series of events that
included a great battle the death of
gods like odin and the earth ultimately
being flooded the aztecs meanwhile not
only believed that the world would end
they believed that it already had ended
on four previous occasions first it was
destroyed by jaguars then by a hurricane
then by a rain of fire and then by a
great flood this flooding thing is a bit
of a theme
next it was going to be destroyed in an
earthquake in fact for the aztecs the
end of the world was an event which had
to be constantly warded off by human
sacrifices to help keep the sun alive
but in our opinion no one else has ever
really quite done the end times quite
like christianity the story of
revelation closes out the bible telling
us in no uncertain terms that when the
end does come it'll make the final
episode of game of thrones look like
child's play including lots of fire and
dragons of course at the end christ
returns and redeems everything and
there's no more suffering and death but
this brand new start is of course
predicated on a bunch of destruction
proving that there's really no such
thing as a free lunch throughout the
past couple of centuries religious
leaders fringe writers charlatans and
cultists of various stripes have
confidently predicted that all the world
was going to end often on some definite
date and maybe even very soon
in the middle ages some people got
really fired up about the year 1000 with
the millennium of christ's birth kicking
off a wave of apocalyptic mania that
ended up being
pretty anticlimactic over the course of
the next millennium plenty of the
apocalyptic hungry faithful would
wrongly believe that the end times had
finally come these included the
millerites an american doomsday sect
from the middle of the 19th century who
prepared for the apocalypse not once but
three times before eventually giving up
and deciding they'd have to commit to
being alive all the time you might say
was miller time members of the group
later founded the 7th day adventist
church which now claims over 20 million
members 18 million of whom have knocked
on your door meanwhile over the course
of the 20th century the apocalypse got
even weirder with groups like heaven's
gate preaching that the end of the world
will be brought about through ufos which
is definitely more
creative than the terrifyingly plausible
possibility that the earth might be
destroyed through man-made climate
change but whether or not you're in an
actual cult the sense that we're all
about to die has steadily become more
universal but why have people always
been so obsessed with the end of the
world one general fact about apocalypse
narratives is that even though the end
of humankind would be very bad the
apocalypse brings about an ultimately
positive result at the end of the
ragnarok story two human survivors are
supposed to repopulate the earth after
the flood after christ's second coming
death no longer exists after the ufos
come the cult members will transcend
their physical bodies and realize some
sort of paradise than outer space plus
matching sneakers and track suits
interestingly one interpretation of the
revelation narrative is that it was
actually a story told by persecuted
members of the early christian church to
comfort themselves one day the old world
would fall and the emperor would stop
feeding you to lions for sport the end
of the world is therefore supposed to
redeem humankind or at least the people
who did or believed the right thing if
the world around you sucks it's very
comforting to hope that a fresh start is
right around the corner this is
especially the case for historically
oppressed groups who were waiting for
some kind of messiah to destroy this
shitty world and create a new one
grounded in some type of justice
psychoanalysts like freud have offered
their own interpretations on this
religious narrative using the concept of
the death drive to explain the
fundamental human instinct to revert
back towards an inorganic state and in
his work civilization and its
discontents freud argues that the reason
we have a civilization in the first
place is to contain fundamental human
aggressions caused by this death drive
on this reading the desire for the end
of life is just sort of wired into our
unconscious one good boy who read freud
was frankfurt school critical theorist
theodore adorno adorno lived through the
rise of the nazis escaped the holocaust
by fleeing to america which he hated and
witnessed the invention of the atom bomb
for him all of this was a sign that life
was so irredeemably bad that he named it
the wrong life according to adorno right
living was no longer possible for him
this extended from seriously awful
things like death camps to pleasant
things like jazz all the way down to
banal things like door handles and
refrigerators no seriously he wrote
about this stuff adorno explored these
thoughts in his book minimum moralia a
sort of philosophical document of his
experiences in exile in america to
understand minimum oralia imagine a book
written by larry david if he just read
loads of hegel instead of writing about
soup nazis and no fap contest after
approximately 200 or so pages detailing
the many ways in which modern life both
sucks and is completely hopeless adorno
declares that actually we can do one
good thing in the book's final section
aptly titled finale he writes that the
only philosophy which can be responsibly
practiced in the face of despair is the
attempt to contemplate all things as
they would present themselves from the
standpoint of redemption we have to
develop perspectives adorno said that
displace and estrange the world reveal
it to be with its rifts and crevices as
indigene and distorted as it will appear
one day in the messianic light so in
short if everything is terrible if all
life is wrong and we can't live it
rightly there's still one thing we can
do
look forward to the rapture now adorno's
messianism was merely theoretical he
just thought people should try to think
about the world as if the messiah was
about to come down and finally set
everything right but it's certainly
possible to see how this sort of
thinking might translate into a yearning
for the literal apocalypse an
alternative to adorno's messianism can
be found in the work of german
philosopher walter benjamin for benjamin
an apocalyptic hell wasn't in the near
future it was already here for the
majority of the world's oppressed people
but unlike adorno he thought
revolutionary politics was all about
bringing about a messianic moment in
which time would rupture this would mean
the end of the old world and the birth
of something new in this way theological
redemption becomes political redemption
of course this argument might sound
slightly odd when applied to climate
change or nuclear war after all how are
those potentially apocalyptic events
supposed to be redeeming what sort of
messianism is to be found in the world
burning and that's not surprising humans
tend to like being right to the point
where when something huge is on the line
it easily devolves into moral absolutism
like say
the end of the world or you know whether
pineapple belongs on pizza the doomer
mindset makes its own sort of sense the
doomer has abandoned any possibility of
hope and they may find that comforting
maybe the world will end maybe the world
will end soon but at least if it does
the doomer won't have been wrong in
their minds the optimistic people those
who thought that maybe the end of the
world might have been prevented will not
only have to endure the end of all
things they'll also have been very wrong
as the flaming comets fall to earth
they'll know they've been played for
chumps
but this idea that the world is already
definitely ending an idea shared by our
friend beau burnham
as explored by philosophers and
anthropologists writing about the
anthropocene i.e the era of earth that
has been marked by humankind's
domination of geology and ecology many
of these theorists think the age of the
anthropocene and thus humanity is
absolutely coming to an end and that
it's all our fault scholar gregory marks
in an essay on the end of the world
quotes deborah danowski and eduardo
viveros to castro as saying that it is
certain that although it began with us
it will end without us the anthropocene
will only give way to a new geological
epoch long after we have disappeared
from the face of the earth so if the end
of the world ever comes it will almost
certainly be our fault but that's
weirdly good news because even if you
don't have a lot of power you do have
some it might not be obvious what we
ought to do but we do have at least some
control over our lives and thus in some
small way over the fate of the species
as a whole this is what jean-paul sart
meant when he said that existence
precedes essence while we might find
ourselves restricted in many ways there
is something about humanity which makes
us free to define ourselves in relation
to those restrictions to spot
possibilities for action and choose to
actualize them whenever we can and what
happens when we don't embrace that
freedom when we use external
circumstances as an excuse for our
inaction that's what sark called bad
faith for him our freedom means that we
are without excuse
we are responsible for our own actions
for the good or bad we do within
whatever conditions we happen to find
ourselves dumerism on the other hand
seeks to give everyone the ultimate
excuse there's no point doing anything
since we're all going to die soon anyway
that said even sart shifted his position
in his later work where he tried to fuse
the existentialist emphasis on human
freedom with a marxist emphasis on
social inequality he eventually argued
that even our freedom can be limited by
material conditions and that it is
actually the work of collective human
projects to affect any real change in
the world for sartre the looming end of
the world would be just the type of
threat that could unify disparate humans
together into what he would call a group
infusion people who previously had
nothing in common could be rallied and
united in the mission of stopping the
apocalypse for him this totalizing doom
might be just the sort of thing that
could lead to an uprising of real
collective freedom
so it'd be like if there was let's say i
don't know a a looming ecological crisis
on the horizon that was certain to
radically alter all human life and those
humans could get together and use their
collective power to stop that thing from
happening or something like that does
that sound crazy is that a crazy example
that the world is then we get together
we try to fix it is that stupid am i
crazy are you crazy is anyone i don't
know
so what do you all think would the
apocalypse really be the ultimate excuse
to never pay back our student loans do
we all really secretly think that the
end times are coming and if so what does
that train of thought do to a culture
let us know in the comments hit that
subscribe button like it's the flip top
on a can of beans in your fallout
shelter and don't forget to ring that
bell
thanks as always to our patrons for all
your support and if you have not checked
out our patreon page recently please do
we have a lot of good stuff and we think
you'll be really into it as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
you